let's start with Jennifer Hale first of
all Jennifer what's your question do you
think in TV debates will have an impact
on her people of all in the election and
I hope so I think they'll have an impact
on how some people will I mean obviously
a lot of people already know how they're
going to vote and are quite firm in
their opinion about how they're going to
walk but and all from speaking to a lot
of people who watch the first of the UK
leaders debates that if they were under
say do beforehand it's helped them make
up their minds because they've heard you
know the different policies of the
different parties and they've seen
something of the different leaders so I
think it does help some people last
night's to be obviously David Cameron
and Nick Clegg we're there and so it was
a more limited in how mentioned it did I
know in that case I must mention it no
David Cameron wimped out of the debate
last night yeah I hope so and people
these days I think probably get that
information in lots of different ways so
Twitter and Facebook can you know other
online sources as really and Pettis with
he has just introduced me to periscope
which is looks fantastic and so people
get their information and form their
opinions and all sorts of different ways
no but hopefully the TV debates have
played a part in that happy Thomas if
Pena balls state the the seriously
artist now in the SNP returned a large
amount of seats how much influence will
you as an MSP have over the elected
Westminster MPs well firstly and I I
always feel the need to see this I think
it's really important that we're still
three weeks away from an election the
opinion polls look fantastic for the SNP
but I've got lots of elections of lost
let elections as well as one simulation
so you should never take waters for
granted will be working really hard to
persuade people to vote folders because
I vote for the SMP years of ought to
meet Scotland's voice haired and I think
the influence of the SNP in the House of
Commons can lead to better politics in
the House of Commons so that's the
message will continue to take two people
every day of the campaign if the SMP do
when a lot of seats in the House of
Commons I'm the leader of the SNP saw
our overall strategy and how we approach
things in the house
I'll be leading that and directing that
obviously on a day to day basis our MPs
will be making the decisions on the
ground and in the House of Commons but
the SNP's always one of our glutes
strengths as a party actually is that
we've always worked as a very cohesive
team between our msps and the Scottish
Parliament and our MPs in the House of
Commons and I think that teamwork will
be all the more important if we do
manage to win a big number of seats
let's bring in Francesca hash army is
that i renounce your Treasury hachey me
hey you bum Lisicki and my question is
in Scotland there was a hundred and
twenty thousand college places cut what
could we offer to those people who
missed over well what we've done in
terms of college education as we've
partly because of the recession we
focused college education very much and
giving young people the skills they need
to get jobs so the number of full-time
equivalent places in college has
actually increased and the number of
people getting recognised qualifications
in colleges has increased as as well and
we need to keep that focus and you know
in a sense the proof of the pudding is
in the eating we've seen youth
unemployment fall in Scotland it's still
too high but it's much lower than it was
and were spending more money in college
ease now than was the case with labor
when in government so you know I'm proud
of what we are doing in education in
schools and colleges and universities
and given more child care but you're
right in the sense we've got to this is
one of the things I feel very strongly
about that we need to make sure we're
providing a range of different
educational opportunities for people I
mean I was very proud to go to Glasgow
University University is not for
everybody so as well as making sure
those opportunities at colleges we've
also been increasing the number of
modern apprenticeships the last time i
was in irvin which is where i grew up
but last time i visited to you i went to
visit at GSK the from pharmaceutical
company that's based on irvin to talk to
some of their apprentices and young
girls in particular who would have been
totally capable of going to university
but chose the modern apprenticeship
because he thought that was better for
them so we need to have that range of
different opportunities and will
continue to work hard to make sure we do
ok Callan booth next considering that
this is an election for the Westminster
Parliament it's understandable that you
will always want to stand up for the
interests of the Scottish people do you
think that it is feared that people in
England and Wales receive less funding
because of the bionet formula than those
in Scotland and Ireland well I I don't
accept that Scotland is subsidized
Scotland more than peers it's we in the
UK you know if you look back almost all
of my lifetime for the last 34 years of
1 i'll leave that all done i thought
before but not watch and Scotland's
generated more tax per head of
population than the UK as a whole so we
pee in and were not subsidized no it's
no secret that I wanted Scotland to be
an independent country Scotland hasn't
voted to be an independent country at
this stage as long as we park the
Westminster system therefore it's really
important that Scotland's voices haired
and that we have a big influence on the
decisions that are taken at Westminster
but I will always always challenge this
notion that Scotland is somehow
subsidized from the rest of the UK
because we contribute strongly and we PR
we do you think that if you do enter our
coalition on confidence is supplied
dealing with labor that if you have to
represent the entire country as a whole
that I think its name percent of the
country Arpaio Scotland and Ireland an
eighty percent of the country from the
rest of the use of the UK who did not
benefit from from Barnett consequentials
do you think that when there's a problem
where people do not feel they
represented by the government that this
will create an internal problem with
people looking towards you as a head of
the government or whoever takes over the
government I hope no I mean one of the
things I've been very anxious to try to
do in this campaign is senior photos
outside of Scotland that you know albeit
yes then all the SMP what's gotten to be
an independent country but for as long
as we are part of the Westminster system
they don't and shouldn't see the SNP is
something to be you know scared all
because it matters to us that that I
give decisions taken at Westminster and
I want to build alliances with people
who share similar views to the SNP
whatever they love in the UK
that we can try and get better politics
oh I don't want the SMP to be seen in
that way and i expect we've got a
responsibility to demonstrate that we
will be constructive players in the
Westminster system f people in Scotland
work folders in big numbers and I take
that responsibility very seriously I
also you know people in Scotland know
that we've had many many years in fact
more than half of my life where we've
had to put up with Tory government's
even ago people in Scotland having
bought it Tory and and you know if we
have the UK and if we have the
Westminster system then you know
sometimes these things happen through
the Westminster system and I think it
would be wrong for anybody to see that
Scotland didn't have the right to make
its voice haired at this election
because we do and all the evidence
suggests people's court and want to make
their voice head I mean burns wants to
take that one step further don't you
there how much wondering what do you
think it's fair to tax the rest of the
UK to fund like the Scottish NHS and
other Scottish public services well I
don't I don't accept that
characterization you know we fund our
public services from the taxis weepy in
Scotland and Scotland's in deficit as
the yukia's and deficits of the UK as a
whole and Scotland as part of the UK it
spends more than we reason in revenues
and obviously one of the important
things we've got to do is get that
deficit down but in a responsible way
but I don't accept this notion that it's
taxis and other parts of the UK that pay
for our public services is the taxis
weepy here the P for our public services
and I think laws to try and suggest that
Scotland has subsidized by the rest of
the UK do a real disservice to people in
Scotland Charlotte young girls pregnant
woman leader maybe leader in British
politics in recent times the last be in
love that sure what do you think your
similarities and differences are to her
well um I suppose the similarity as it
were both women and I think probably
there are more differences than
similarities that he and I were talking
a little and I was brought up to believe
you shouldn't speak ill of people who
are no longer with us and margret
thatcher's no longer with us and so I'll
temper my comments that because of that
about it that's when I was growing up
represented much of what i thought was
wrong with politics so in some ways she
was one of the people who motivated me
to get involved to campaign against the
kind of politics and policies that she
pursued she was the first woman Prime
Minister think I was named when she was
elected and yeah I remember even though
I was very young the sense of having a
woman in that job I think what
disappointed a lot of people was that
she didn't really do anything to help
other women so you know all these years
since there's still not been another
woman Prime Minister and I would hope
although I have to be judged on what I
do not what i see i would want one of
the big differences between me as the
first minute part of women First
Minister and Margaret Thatcher's the
first women play minister is that I will
try to use the possession I've got now
to help other women not just in politics
but in every walk of life so that we can
in the not-too-distant future genuinely
see that we've got equal rights for
women if you're good enough and you work
hard enough there shouldn't be a glass
ceiling holding you back and it really
is one of the things that's very
important to me is to use my position to
advance opportunity for other one let me
bring in Daniel Levy who's tweeted is
actually on that box she says given your
popularity outside of Scotland would you
consider running for p.m. in 2020 no I'm
going to continue to seek to be a member
of the Scottish Parliament and I hope
I'll still be First Minister in 2020
I'll have to win an election in scotland
next year then I take nothing for
granted with that but and yeah I want to
be frost Minister of Scotland for as
long as I feel like in make a difference
being fresh Minister of Scotland and
that's when I want to to practice my
politics here in Scotland and the
Scottish Parliament it but I do want a
very very much want as the leader of the
SNP but as long as Scotland is part of
the UK and partly Westminster system I
want the SNP to play a role in trying to
deliver better policies for people right
across the UK I want us to be
constructive and positive and to build
alliances and find common ground with
others who share our views even added 11
Scotland whatever they happen till of
miyuki and reread okay
during the referendum did the SNP have a
plan in place f skull under an
independent country were not immediately
accepted entity you or rejected from the
year given the impact that would have
had and trade down the economy as a
whole hey no because in my view that was
never ever any doubt that Scotland would
be part of the European Union are
continuing part of the little bit even
if so does Delhi a leaky I believe years
we weren't no i I've never and you're we
literally things in depth then carefully
I don't think there was ever any risk of
that happening at for Scotland I mean
the European Union is a an institution
that from almost the day I know where
that it was established has existed to
expand itself and the idea that the
European Union would have tried to cut
off part of its territory just because
that part of it stated she had 40
democratically to be independent I think
if the European Union had even
temporarily put Scotland outside I think
he would have created and a huge crisis
for the European Union itself because it
would have been effectively punishing at
part of its territory for exercising a
democratic rate and the craters that
would have caused in the heart of Europe
I think would have been attained so I
don't think there was ever any chance of
that I her different countries have
waited years to be on the European Union
would feel about that given calms his
walkins immediately I think we wouldn't
be walking in what already end so Scott
has been a part of the European Union as
part of the UK for 40 years or so we
comply with our European directives and
regulations and legislation you know we
are compliant with all of the rules and
regulations of the European Union
countries coming in the reason it takes
so long is because they've got to
demonstrate that they do comply with all
of that there wouldn't have been a
question mark over that for Scotland
because we've been integral an integral
part of the EU for so long there's also
you know we know how many i represent
associated glasgow in the scottish
parliament there are in the thousands of
nationals of other european countries
living in my constituency and guys going
in other parts of scotland as there are
people from Scotland living in other
European countries so with an integral
part of the European Union and it would
have been you people talk during the
referendum about the problems for
Scotland if
that had not been the case with problems
for the rest of the European Union would
have been significant so it was you know
it was one of the scare stories we had
in the referendum any scare stories but
one of the ones that i think was more
ridiculous even than any of the other
ones hannah both obviously austerity can
cause problems for some people and you
have a lot of plans to make some small
and manor spending increases how will
you be able to fund these and where will
your spending and casey's be well what
we're putting forward in this campaign
is an alternative to the continued
austerity spending cuts that the Tories
want to introduce and Lee Bowden the
Liberal Democrats are signed up to what
effectively we're seeing is that we take
a slightly slower piece to eliminating
the deficit so we allow spending to
increase fairly modest Lee and proposing
about half a percent above inflation and
every year of the next parliament and
that's still allows you to just the
deficit year-on-year but it means that
by the end of the next parliament the
deficit wouldn't be completely
eliminated it would take two or three
years after that no I think that's a
place worth paying to ease up on the
pain of the spending cuts that have been
imposed over the past five years and
that are planned to continue because
what those cuts are doing are driving
more people into poverty they're making
it harder to protect the initiation of
public services and that actually this
is the biggest I'd any of the Tory a
steady T policy here that actually
holding back the growth in our economy
George Osborne messed all of his own
fiscal targets because he constrained
economic growth so if you invest a bit
more than infrastructure and skills and
innovation the things that get your
economy growing ironically you were just
a deficit faster because you'll have a
faster glue and accordingly with more
people paying taxes so that's what I'm
proposing a slightly slower path of
deficit reduction in order that we can
start investing again and the things
that really matter how exactly will you
pay for these of the Labour Party and
you kept have already been able to walk
em that they will be able to provide all
the funding for their policies can you
do this to do
we're proposing a small reduction in
borrowing so that would be the first
difference we also though support some
of Labor's proposals on tax rises so we
support the restoration of the 50 pence
top rate of tax we would support a
mansion tax we would support the
proposals that they're putting forward
for our bankers say bonus tax and a bank
levy so that our revenue raising at
proposals that that we support that
would help to raise revenue but the
difference between us and labor is that
we are proposing that slightly lower
it's slower rather reduction in
borrowing borrowing still coming down
but it's coming down at a slightly
slower e to give more room for spending
increases what are your policies funded
a yes by a combination of the slow
reduction in borrowing and the revenue
reason a proposals that municipal let's
move on to Charlotte is just behind you
there now well again we know that you
willing to go into a collision with
labor but who do respect mah David
Cameron I tad Miliband Emma I don't
really based on personality i don't i
said this a few times that i don't know
why the david miliband even know i did
not today sorry David Miliband story ATM
I don't know ed Miliband or David
Cameron all that whale I mean I think
last night and the leaders to be it was
probably the third time only that I've
met Ed Miliband think I've met David
Cameron slightly more because as foster
minister he's plain Minister we've had
more occasion to meet so don't know them
personally all that way i look at the
policies I will never ever be part of
supporting a Tory government because I
think Tony governments have been really
damaging to Scotland and we had an n 00
earlier on and a doll yeah so those oh
yeah I don't think are being coalition
or they're sent people being coalition
with Lee but either former coalition's
never really had been something that I
felt likely would we support labor on an
issue by issue basis yes I've made it
clear that we would weave it also if
there's more anti Tory MPs than Tory MPs
we'd be prepared to vote to keep the
Tories from ever getting back into
government so those are the kind of
deals or arrangements if you like that I
would be prepared to see the SNP do but
clear that the point of having SNP MPs
is to meet Scotland's voice haired but
also then to try to deliver a real
change and the point I was making Ted
Miliband last night is that I want to
get rid of the Tories but I don't want
them to see yet to any government
replaced by a Tory late government I
want to see the toilets replaced by
something that's going to be better than
the toilets and bawled out and actually
deliver progressive change for people
and that the deference I think SMP MPs
can make we can push shared Miliband and
labor to be a bit believer in boulder
and what they're going to do and one of
the sticking points might be Thomas's
next question hey you've put a trading
at the top of the agenda with any
potential talks with political parties
looking ahead from a practice point of
view with these talks and we're else in
the British Isles can you a comedy or
house trident I don't weren't trying to
be accommodating to host anywhere they
also i'm opposed to nuclear weapon so at
my position is not get traded out
scotland and put it somewhere else my
position is get trident Oh Phil salt
whether or not a UK government wanted to
but Trident somebody else would be a
matter for them but I don't I don't want
us to have nuclear weapons the decision
that's coming up in the next parliament
always about whether we renew the
Trident missile system and I take the
view that as well as my principled
opposition to nuclear weapons at a time
you know we can sit here at Cal and I
talking about austerity a time when you
know those money is really tight and
we're having to talk about whether we
can afford to invest more than the NHS
orden left some kids out of poverty
daddy that were just gonna Chuck 100
billion pounds at a new system and
nuclear weapons Shakespeare's totally
the wrong priorities saw SNP MPs will
argue that we shouldn't renew trader and
we will seek to build alliances in the
House of Commons that can prevent the
renewal of Trident the moment we have
tradin so you're gonna do have to get
rid of Trident or put it somewhere else
with the tray that we have what happens
welfare how do you dispose of it or
where else can you fit it I don't well
you're not going to get me to see pitch
rising somewhere else I won't try them
to be decommissioned that I don't want
it to go somewhere else I don't want any
other community have to have to have
tried I'm opposed to nuclear weapons
what I'm
just saying it will take some time no of
course it well and I've always accepted
that but you know the key decision point
in the next parliament is do we renew
trident so if you decide not to renew
try it then you know you they're not an
appeal if we're trying to well over a
period of years it ceased to be there if
your renewal idn't it effectively
signing up it's a whole new generation
of nuclear weapons and that's the the
point of decision will face in the next
parliament and the SNP will vote against
that if it does get renewed will that be
it fazli in scotland well if the UK
government is deciding that then I'm
pretty sure their plan will be to put it
at Faslane again I don't want the whole
trident to be debate to be about Faisal
universities another part of the UK i
won as not to renew trident full stop
and incidentally I argued we argued in
the referendum if Scotland had become an
independent country faz lean as a base
would have been kept open as a
conventional naval base it's not fazli
in the facility i went to seagull it's
the Trident nuclear weapons I want to
sequel and that brings us nicely onto
another question from Twitter as far as
the greens are concerned obviously they
would agree with you in that aspect but
Michael Adams on twitter says why is the
SMP so close to the Greens whose
policies are anathema to Scotland's
greatest resource IE North Sea on I mean
the SNP in the greens are two different
parties so we don't agree on as many
many things we're doing a glee on we
campaign together in Scotland and the
independence referendum there are things
I would agree with the green zone we've
just been talking about one of them
trident I've got a great deal of time
for the leader of the greens and
Scotland Patrick Harvie and you know
I've got to know natalie bayonet we bet
during the leaders debates but there are
many policy differences between the SNP
in the greens we think at making sure
that we maximize the resource we've got
in the North Sea responsibly is
important they would take a different
view of that where we agree around
energy is that we need to make sure we
also maximize Scotland's renewable
energy potential a wind we've tidal
energy potential salt there are areas
with agree on but there are significant
areas where we disagree which is why
we're too
separate parties Jennifer you pledged
that women will make up fifty percent of
word rooms by 2020 her d plan to achieve
this well I would like to be able to
legislate to give a real shove behind
that we don't the poet and the Scottish
Parliament right now to legislate in
these things because equality's
legislation is still one of the reserved
matter so what I'm going to do is
strongly encouraged and at cajal and
motivate a companies and public boards
to do it one of the most important
things or what i thought was one of the
most important things that i had to do
was lead by example so when I appointed
my cabinet after becoming First Minister
I made sure my cabinet was gender
balanced we're I think it's pretty
shocking actually there's so I'm told
only three countries in the developed
world that have gender balance cabinets
that's pretty sure but I'm proud
Scotland's one of them and interestingly
I got letters and emails after I did
that people asking me how I knew that
all of the women in my cabinet will lead
on merit nobody asked me how I knew or
remain and my cabinet were there or made
it but course of the day in my cabinets
they don't made it women are more than
fifty percent of the population when we
should question matter is when we see
organizations are not gender balanced
because you know given that women are
fifty percent of the population that's
when we should see as everybody there
really they don't made it so I've led by
example I'll continue to lead by example
and I will do everything possible to
encourage others to follow suit I I feel
very passionately about gender equality
partly because as a country if we're not
allowing women to contribute fully we're
not making the most of our own potential
as a country and but partly just because
i want to see ghettos and women have
opportunities to follow their dreams and
do what they want and I've got re nice
who's eat nearly nine it's more like
this and then like this isn't she and
she's getting she's yeah she's probably
not far off being taller than me
actually if it sure will eventually come
to the school and but I've got this
thing in my head and in my heart
actually the time she's a young woman I
us to have solved some of these problems
of the pay gap and gender segregation
and under representation so that her
generation doesn't have to do that these
battles can be won and i think we are
now a stage where we can win these
battles i can pull you apart and that i
can do it all on my own but if we really
be concerted effort then for her
generation we can win these battles and
she can grow up you know never doubting
the fact that she can be anything she
wants to be if she's good enough and
what's hard enough here here Francesca
it seems that every other weekend or so
in Glasgow a young women probably around
my age is attacked or raped walking home
from work or a night out how do you
address that as a society without
turning into a big big surveillance
heavy place it's a really am it's a
really important question Francesca it's
also really timely question obviously
given the horrendous events in Glasgow
over the past need to be a bit careful
with it although obviously I but in you
know my thoughts and everybody's
thoughts are with their the family of
that young woman just no but and your
question is how do we meet women safe in
the streets and I think the first thing
we should do is is to say that women
generally are safe walking the streets
of Glasgow and any other city most than
this is short a shocking thing to see as
well in the last few months yes I'm from
Glasgow you know a lot of my friends age
as well we're now not feeling the air
that we used to I'm no I'm not trying to
disagree with you I get I'm gonna come
mornin and try and address your question
what I was going to see the was it is
still the case and this in itself is
shocking and has to be addressed that
most women who attacked will be attacked
by somebody in their own home somebody
they know rather than by somebody random
unknown to them in the street so I don't
say that to disagree with you just to
put it into context I love in Glasgow as
well so yeah I spoken to young women who
would see exactly what you've said that
whether it's real or whether it's a
perception that is less of our
confidence about walking the streets
than we need to
deal with that we need to do that
through police presence on the streets
we need to do it through I guess you
know solidarity and been very very clear
as women that were not going to allow
ourselves to be you know uncie phone on
the streets and we've got to tackle
every single in every area of society
the idea that violence of any form
against women is acceptable it's
unacceptable in whatever form it takes
and we've got to make sure we're
supporting the efforts and the agencies
and the organizations that work to help
that there's no one single answer if I
could sit here and give you the one
single Magic Bullet answer believe me I
would do it and you know I went to
university in Glasgow I've lived in
Glasgow know since I was 18 years old
and when I was at University you know I
walked about the streets of Glasgow on
my own at night my mother used to go
fetch if she's listening to that she
will go mad he let me see that and and
felt totally see if I've always felt
safe in Glasgow and I do not worn any
young women no not feeling safe on the
streets of the city that I'm you know so
close at all well there isn't a magic
answer that you can give to this but I
feel like the pragmatic answer is a
police presence and the worst thing I
think that could happen is this perverse
effect of people in Glasgow feeling less
safe because the police are patrolling
quite feminine Utley well there's got to
be a balance in these things a police
presence visible police presence makes
people feel safer and you don't want the
police to be intrusive and all of that
so you've got to get that balance rate
but we absolutely as a city have to see
very clearly that we want the streets of
our city to be safe for a woman for
everybody and you know last summer we
had the most wonderful experience in
Glasgow with the Commonwealth Games
where we had full from all over the
world at Glasgow is a friendly city it
is in Bahia international standards a
safe city but you know there's no point
me sitting here than seeing that if
young woman like you don't feel safe so
if that's what you're saying to me I
take that very seriously and we
have to make sure that we are doing what
needs to be done to make young women
feel safe in what I think is one of the
best cities in the world we've got
another couple of questions and Andrew
first okay m Avila smart n cold one word
which in 2011 suffered indignity have
been cold their facial wash 10 in
Scotland but since then sm factor the
work of local volunteers and local
volunteer group such as lemon Community
Development Trust is began to thrive
however such groups rely heavily upon
local government for funding funding
which is afraid from cuts thrown both
Holy Writ and Westminster so how can the
S&P justify such cuts the source said to
believe in the fourth sector in the
volunteer sector as a whole gonna have
to take lens question at the same time
where is Liam we have you've got one
more question you haven't you because
we're slightly running out of time so I
just want to ask do you think that an
SMP being part of any coalition would be
beneficial in any way to the rest of the
UK after me okay let me take discretion
especially I think I think when was a
great place rusli and and I also think
the work that Community Development
Trust do is is really valuable and
important those Community Development
trust my own constituencies and all how
important they can be and whatever it c
is is not me making excuses to don't
heal it that way but you put your finger
on one of the key reasons why i want to
have an alternative to father austerity
cuts within the position of scotland
where the budget the scottish parliament
has to spend is determined by
westminster and if they are carrying on
with cuts our budget gets cut as part of
that process and with the base well in
the world we can in a immunize and
initially everything from those cuts so
we protect the health service budget
we're trying to protect the budgets that
we think I'm most important but when the
scottish government budgets been cut by
over and above and flesh and ten percent
since 2010 you can stop everybody
feeling the effects of that and that is
why I want Lacey an alternative a new
equation was I think coalition or the
SNP working with others can be good for
this yes I do and because i think if we
help to make the next Westminster
Government more progressive and have an
alternative test arity and protect our
public services that's going to benefit
Scotland
for other parts of the UK as well if we
can be that force for a more progressive
politics then I'm really keen that we do
that and I'm afraid with that we are out
of time thank you all very much indeed
for your questions at some questions if
they were and I'm sure that you won't
show your appreciation to the first
sentence to thank you pinon excellent
you've exhausted questions election
things that people always go away you
seen I just think here to keep watch
against my fastest later nature is right
he's great yeah